voici le premier entrepôt volant
d'amazon des drones et récupère des
colis qui seront livrés chez vous en
moins de 30 minutes
il ne s'agit pas d'un canular enfin pas
tout à fait amazon détient déjà le
brevet qui pourrait lui permettre de
réaliser cela
pour vous
le fondateur d'amazon est prête à tout
jeff bezos ce est obsédé par la
satisfaction des consommateurs
il a créé une multitude de gadgets qui
lui permettent de vous suivre pas à pas
de vous voir et de vous entendre il a
même trouvé une façon de briser votre
solitude
bonjour madeleine je vous souhaite une
belle journée
il a dépensé des fortunes pour mettre au
point des robots qui manipulent et livre
vos achats en un temps record amazon est
en train de redéfinir les habitudes des
consommateurs à la grandeur du monde
mais quelle est la face cachée de ses
prouesses ici au canada le danger c'est
vraiment les temps du monopole et la
profondeur qu'elle est en train de
prendre toutes les facettes d'un ami qui
frappe vraiment c'est que amazon réussi
à payer de l'impôt seront toute petite
partie de ses revenus totaux download
the stars je ne comprends pas
qu'il puisse agir comme ils le font
wattez de haut
[Musique]
pour voir l'envers du sourire d'amazon
nous sommes allés à leur rencontre
d'entrepreneurs qui ont fait le grand
saut sur la place de marché
officie aujourd'hui dans mon usine à
québec où on fabrique mais bob
jonathan leclercq est un passionné de la
chaussure il est co propriétaire du
fabricant martineau nos produits sont
100 % canadien tout est fait ici dans l'
usine en une soixantaine de personnes
qui travaillaient toutes les étapes
jonathan vend ses créations dans sa
boutique du vieux québec et donc
plusieurs magasins du canada et du nord
des états unis mais ça ne lui suffit pas
et des consommatrices comme vous il y en
a 300 millions à travers les états-unis
pijper capable d'aller les rencontrer en
parler dans quelques semaines jonathan
va lancer ses mocassins sur amazon
amazon c'est une vitrine c'est une
énorme vitrine pour un homme presque
incalculable de consommateurs
amazon et la place de marché la plus
populaire au monde auprès des
consommateurs 200 millions d'abonnés
prime payant
3500 nouveaux vendeurs chaque jour
475 milliards de dollars de ventes en
2020 je suis inquiet aux deux extrémités
ou de pouvoir de résultat ou d'avoir
trop peu de prêtres capable de soutenir
la demande
[Musique]
sur amazon tout est possible
gimont sur leurs seins j'ai fait une
démission cégep puis
pour moi je tombais sur lui un modèle
d'affaires qui amazon et ça m'a vraiment
sauté aux yeux waouh quel à parsemain
t16 ça faisait que le sens à mes yeux
love panzera marin
marcoule roux est un des nombreux
enfants prodiges d'amazon un masque
respiratoire
c'est le premier produit qu'il a mise en
vente
j'ai en ce sens 2016 la première journée
que j'étais
live on peut dire j'ai fait par celui de
vanves première journée là l'année
dernière marco a vendu pour 1,6 million
de dollars de masques c'est mon grand
plus puissant
c'est un autre parcours en maintenant
une trentaine de produits il les fait
fabriquer en chine il n'a pas d'entrepôt
à part son cabanon et pas d'employer
toutes les tâches ingrates amazon les
faits pour lui on aura nos stocks c'est
tout là que les pma ils font les liera
bourse mal sur sa clientèle
comme 92% des vendeurs sur amazon marco
utilisent le service fbi a full field by
amazon en france est expédiée par amazon
un service qui n'est pas donné chaque
aux confins de vente amazon espère 15%
l'émission
ensuite il est frais de marque étaient
les frais de livraison les frais 2-2
d'entreposage l'an dernier 47 % du
montant des ventes de marco s'est
retrouvé dans les poches d'amazon c'est
ce que williams annonce les grands
gagnants de toute somme il faut le voir
le côté le côté pauvres ça c'est que
profit offrir au vendeur une
infrastructure qu'aucune autre place de
marché en ligne n'est capable de
concurrencer ça a été l'un des traits de
génie de jeff les sauces je remercie
dieu
alors
oui les brillants mais il est diabolique
c'est un génie diabolique
l'entrepreneur mike white celle de noël
au québec des tests amazon autant que
marco leroux la vénère
les ventes constamment des façons
d'augmenter leur chiffre d'affaires au
détriment des tms
l'histoire de mike représente bien celle
de nombreux vendeurs
et
aux états unis un sous-comité du
gouvernement vient de mener une enquête
sur les pratiques anti concurrentielles
des gaffes à l'égout go à pau facebook
et amazon il a été mis en lumière qu
amazon app usé de sa position dominante
pour maltraiter ses vendeurs
c'est simple en fait notre production
pour mike les choses avaient pourtant
bien commencé
il y a dix ans il a lancé ses produits
pour enfants sur amazon des trousses
pour fabriquer des brillants à lèvres
des savons et des bombes de bain prenez
note du mot bombe nous allons y revenir
notre chiffre d'affaires augmentait
chaque année ça allait vraiment bien
les affaires de mike vont trop bien
amazon veut qu'il devienne fournisseurs
ça signifie que vous leur fournissez
votre produit est qu'ils le vendent en
votre nom
il faut savoir qu amazon est un géant à
deux têtes elle est l'opératrice de la
place de marché où les vendeurs comme
mike asséché leurs produits mais elle
est aussi un détaillant elle vend ses
propres produits ou des produits
qu'elles achètent en gros à des
fournisseurs faisant directement
concurrence aux autres vendeurs
le problème c'est que quand tu deviens
fournisseurs
ce n'est plus toi c'est eux qui
contrôlent les plots de
mike ne veut pas qu amazon vente s'est
produit à rabais pour ne pas nuire aux
boutiques qui les vendent aussi ils
refusent de devenir fournisseur pourtant
peu de temps après le bac j'ai remarqué
que mes produits étaient vendus par
amazon
amazon a contourné mike et
s'approvisionnent directement chez son
distributeur américain
amazon me concurrence et il faisait
baisser mais c'est la catastrophe nos
ventes ont baissé de 75 à 80%
pour couronner le tout mike perd le
contrôle de sa fiche produit
on avait embauché des experts et
dépenser de l'argent pour améliorer
notre site
mais quelques jours après avoir fait les
changements ça redevenu comme avant
pendant des semaines mike multiplient
les appels chez amazon mais il n'arrive
à rien alors c'est là que j'ai écrit la
lettre
une lettre adressée à jeff bezos ce
jeu fait 500 mille dollars de ventes par
année avec vous et je risque de perdre
mon entreprise à cause de votre inaction
s'il vous plaît aidez moi
j'ai reçu un appel quelques jours plus
tard d'une femme prénommée glen elle a
dit c'est glen de amazon je travaille
directement sous jeff bezos ce et il m'a
demandé de m'occuper de vos problèmes
j'ai dit glen pourquoi modifiez vous ma
fiche produit elle a dit oh c'est simple
quand on commence à vendre votre produit
on prend le contrôle de votre fiche
j'en revenais pas j'ai dû me lever et
marcher de long en large
le problème c'est que mike ne veut pas
qu amazon vendre ses produits elle a dit
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ce qu'on
fait j-10 est debout sérieuse elle a dit
on voulait que j'en parle à jeff
j'ai dit oui vous devriez vraiment
hewish
s'il pense que c'est juste de faire
concurrence aux vendeurs sur la plate
forme qui lui appartient et qu'il
contrôle icône chose il est dans
l'erreur c'est tellement immoral
l'assaut est mort
amazon n'a pas résolu le problème c'est
mike qui a convaincu son distributeur de
cesser de vendre ses produits à amazon
on est passé à deux doigts de la
faillite
mike a gagné la première manche mais il
n'est pas au bout de ses peines
c'est le temps de célébrer pour jonathan
leclercq
aujourd'hui on expédie nos premiers
produits chez amazon tantôt il vient
chercher ça on a tout misé sur palette
setra partir
d'ici ça devrait
les multiples démarches administratives
imposées par amazon depuis deux mois
sont enfin terminés on avait des
partenaires plus de son cru côté
relation avec amazon et à chaque fois
que j'étais content
c'est le consultant cassiopée morin qui
s'occupe du dossier johnathan malgré le
fait qu'on a réussi à ré par l'état ont
carrément abandonné embûches qui encore
aujourd'hui vont peut-être retarder
certains malades projet cassiopée
travail pour nos batailles une des
nombreuses entreprises qui se sont
développés pour aider les vendeurs à
naviguer dans la jungle amazon c'est
marco l'euro de congédier marc leroux a
senti le filon il a écrit un livre est
fondé lui aussi une entreprise de
coaching en offre des forfaits complets
aux 5000 dollars canadiens marco est
formel on le s'improvise pas vendeur sur
amazon favori résolu
pour françois mazon parce que sinon on
peut vraiment s'arracher les cheveux
les consultants amazon sont devenues
nécessaires à cause des défaillances du
service aux vendeurs affreux sur sa
clientèle amazon vraiment
si genève comme quoi c'est une de leurs
faiblesses c'est un tapis rouge pour les
consommateurs ça l'est peut-être un
petit peu moins pour les marchands
jérôme payet et money cash back oscars
sont les propriétaires de la marque de
jouets kim bout ils vendent sur amazon
mais aussi sur aide si une autre
plateforme de vente en ligne c'est
beaucoup plus simple en général
de faire affaire comme marchand avec
ainsi que amazon juste pour comparer au
cours des trois dernières années on a eu
peut-être trois problèmes avec ketty
alors qu avec amazon ces trois par mois
c'est vraiment le problème qui constitue
la hantise de tous les vendeurs c'est la
suspension de la fiche produit
au moindre petit soupçon on respecte pas
leurs lois ils peuvent suspendre la
fiche produit
complet et loeb un sondé page d'amazon
le plus de revenus c'est ce qui est
arrivé à jérôme et monica en septembre
2019 alors que leurs jouets sont en
vente depuis huit mois amazon exigent un
certificat de sécurité qui n'a jamais
été exigé auparavant un certificat qui
est long à obtenir
et pourquoi cela a pris près de deux
mois
deux mois pendant lesquels les ventes
étaient complètement bloquées
c'était en septembre 7 octobre c'était
juste avant noël
parfois le motif des suspensions est
complètement farfelu c'est que notre
produit a été signalé comme
[Musique]
hazmat ça veut dire matières dangereuses
mike van pourtant des produits pour le
bain
je pense que c'est le mot bomb bomb de
bain ça a levé le drapeau rouge
[Musique]
pour les algorithmes d'amazon une bombe
c'est une bande même si elle est
fabriquée de fécule de maïs
hewson de vous envoyer la fiche
contenant les données de sécurité du
produit et avec n'importe quelle autre
compagnie
la faire se réglerait en une journée
mais pas sur amazon
on a été sera ce match je pense pendant
six mois
encore une fois mike a perdu beaucoup
d'argent mais il est resté sur amazon
une des conclusions de la récente
enquête américaine et qu'amazon est
devenu quasi incontournable
amazon accapare presque 40% des ventes
en ligne aux états unis contre 5 %
seulement pour voir le mic son principal
compétiteur si je me lance une marque
avait été un
jeu presque pas le choix d' au moins
faire un bout sur amazon karl boutet est
un expert en stratégie de commerce de
détail il observe les comportements
d'amazon depuis dix ans la façon que je
pense qu'ils abusent le plus présent
menacées avec la remarque privé de
prendre les atouts de la partenaire qui
vendent leurs plateformes d'en tirer
avantage
amazon aurait elle-même lancé plus de
400 marques de produits dont la
populaire amazon bx à plusieurs reprises
elle a été accusée de profiter des
informations privilégiées dont elle
dispose sur ses vendeurs pour reproduire
leurs produits les plus rentables
déçu aussi le havre d'essling par pic
design et voici le riesling amazon des
en octobre 2020 pic design se rend
compte qu amazon vend un produit très
semblable au siècle est ici c'est un
très bon vendeur
son propriétaire riposte avec une vidéo
satirique
moi je me suis dit
des salles où
je n'étais pas fâché j'étais juste comme
c'est vraiment effrontée
l'appel comment je dirais
everyday
impossible de prouver que des données
privilégiés ont été utilisés dans ce cas
ci mais pas de doute sur la source
d'inspiration même nom même design
lobo presque identique
évidemment le prix n'est pas le même
22 dollars contre 79 ils vont dire que
quand je serai le produit que la
consommatrice le consommateur veut en
utilisant leurs pulsions de pouvoir pour
leur offrir - web de façon moins cher
mais ça fait que ça étouffe ce qui amène
une belle idée ou si la vidéo de piques
design est devenue virale un coup de
publicité incroyable pour la compagnie
un peu moins pour amazon et je suis ont
discrètement cessé de faire le produit
on les a vraiment battu à plate couture
toutes les histoires ne se termine pas
aussi bien
interpellé par les élus américains jeff
bezos ce n'a pas nié que des
informations privilégiées tu avais pu
être utilisées
c'est dans ce monde où la compétition
est féroce et souvent déloyale que
jonathan s'apprête à sauter protesté
demandant de voir comment ça va
fonctionner qu'est ce que ça vient
des millions de consommateurs
découvriront bientôt les mocassins de
jonathan des consommateurs datés par
l'écosystème amazon des fois ce qui est
très efficace et les consommateurs qui
veulent en profiter de ce système
commandé 10 chandail pour un retourné 9
déclaré faussement qu'un article n'a pas
été livrée pour en obtenir un deuxième
gratuitement certains consommateurs sont
vraiment détestable
pensez vous que si me commandait un bon
mocassins loi je retournais une vieille
paire de godasses amazon passé louche
seraient remboursés j'ai entendu dire
que ça pourrait fonctionner je ferais
comment résister à un tel défi on a
commandé une paire de mocassins et on
s'est mis à la recherche d'une part de
godasses on vous en donne des nouvelles
désolé jonathan
[Musique]
bonjour tout le monde on est à la mi
juillet en plein milieu de l'été et ça
fait quelques semaines que nos bacs à
sel sont en vente sur amazon voyez la
semaine passée on a vendu cette part
c'est un départ qui répondent à nos
attentes
un peu la messi ça qu'on s'attendait ont
très hâte de voir la progression des
ventes qui va suivre
une des paire de mocassins vendus par
jonathan leclercq et dans cette boîte
qu'on vient de nous livrer on va faire
un test est il vrai qu'on peut retourner
n'importe quoi chez amazon et se faire
rembourser par le vendeur on met dans la
boîte une vieille paire de mocassins
usagers qu'on a payé 3 dollars à la
place des mocassins jonathan qui valent
75 dollars et on expédie le tout chez
amazon en demandant un remboursement à
suivre
jeff bezos à la fin du mois
avant d'aller plus loin regardons
comment le fondateur d'amazon a bâti son
empire
les capacités de l'entreprise a livré
dur est venu livrer une satisfaction
clientèle
bâtir un empire c'est louis san mc elle
coupe la société
jeff bezos sa faune des amazones en 1994
dans le garage de sa maison située en
banlieue de seattle dans l'état de
washington
27 ans plus tard bge hausse est l'homme
le plus riche est l'un des plus
puissants au monde comme un stratège
d'affaires comme visionnaire d'affaires
qu'il a
[Rires]
des revenus de
386 milliards de dollars américains en
la moitié de ces revenus provient de la
vente des produits qu amazon vend elle
même sur la plateforme le reste provient
des frais payés par les vendeurs des
services info nuages et des abonnements
de la publicité et des magasins
traditionnels
mais la clé de voûte du succès d'amazon
ce n'est pas sa diversification
c'est la patience de ses actionnaires
d'abc quand on investit en compagnie
c'est pour avoir des retours en
dividendes dont aux places parce qu'on
veut on veut que la compagnie nous
retourne de l'argent mais jeff bezos
très tôt a pu convaincre les
investisseurs que c'était à leur
détriment de façon qu'ils devaient
s'attendre à ce que lui investit
continuellement les profits ça semble
aller de soi aujourd'hui mais c'était
révolutionnaire il y en a un temps
[Musique]
c'est vrai que mieux martelé au cours
des dix premières années amazon accumule
des pertes qui totalise des milliards de
dollars
amazon se permet de vendre des produits
et des services à perte en investissant
massivement dans son développement elle
prend une longueur d'avancé qui semble
aujourd'hui pas insurmontable pour faire
face à la zone sont tellement gros
qu'ils appuient pas de stratégie
d'affaires qui vont permettre d'aller
directement face à face à quatre ou même
stewart benz de cosco
réinvestir la majeure partie de ses
profits comporte un autre avantage
l'équation est vraiment faim - ont fait
profite moins on paie l'impôt nous avons
demandé à la fiscaliste brigitte alepin
d'analyser les états financiers d'amazon
ce qui frappe vraiment c'est que hama
sombre réussi à payer que l'impôt sur
une toute petite partie de ses revenus
totaux 30 et 20 premières années
d'opération
entre 1995 et 2000 14 pendant qu amazon
établi sa dominance elle génère 409
milliards de dollars de revenus mais son
bénéfice net avant impôts et 2,4
milliards seulement l'équivalent de 1%
de ses revenus nous avons aussi demandé
à brigitte alpes est d'analyser les
états financiers de deux des concurrents
d'amazon on s'aperçoit que madeco ce qu
ont une partie de leur revenu total qui
devient imposables qui beaucoup plus
élevé que amazon de 1995 à 2014 le
bénéfice net avant impôts de wal mart
représentait
5,3 pour cent ses revenus totaux et
celui de cosco 2,8 pour cent mais ça
s'arrête pas là c'est que sur ce petit
bénéfice
amazon réussi à payer beaucoup
d'impôts que ses concurrents war moscou
ses concurrents dans le monde tangible
si on regarde amazon de ses débuts à
2020 une période de 26 ans on découvre
que sur son petit bénéfice elle a payé
9,8 pour cent d'impôt pendant la même
période
wal mart et cosco paient respectivement
31,8 % et 30 % d'impôts
c'est énorme
lorsqu'on constate qu'une société pgh
est trois fois moins d'impôts que ses
concurrents on peut se laisser aller à
imaginer qu est-ce qui aurait pu faire
les concurrents ces mêmes l'industrie
dans son ensemble s'est elle avait été
imposée à un niveau d'imposition qui est
égal ou similaires un des facteurs qui
expliquent le faible ratio d'impôts
payés par amazon et qu'elle opère dans
le cyberespace et non dans des magasins
physiques
ça permet à amazon de pouvoir
manipuler son revenu puis l'établir dans
les juridictions où est ce que les taux
d'imposition sont les plus faibles alors
que wal mart et cosco sont obligés de
payer un certain degré ds un certain
niveau d'un pont dans chacun des pays où
est ce que les magasins sont installés
amazon paie de l'impôt canada mais a
refusé de nous dire combien par courriel
pour expliquer son faible ratio d'impôts
payés elle nous a écrit les
investissements de capitaux la
rémunération à base d'actions et les
crédits d'impôts au titre de la
recherche et du développement sont
prises en compte dans le calcul de
l'impôt sur le revenu d'amazon aux états
unis ce qui réduit nos obligations
fiscales et notre taux d'imposition
effectif
2 les avantages d'amazon pour l'économie
canadienne sont bien moindres qu'il
pourrait l'être si amazon prenait
certaines mesures joseph braillard et à
des consultants amazon les plus reconnus
au canada je suis la plus grande
conférence amazones du monde dave est
aussi vendeur sur amazon et ce qui
l'inquiète particulièrement c'est la
présence grandissante des vendeurs
chinois sur la plateforme
la maison de façon très intense de
recruter des vendeurs en chine parce que
les vendeurs chinois peuvent offrir des
prix plus bas que les vendeurs basée au
canada comme moi
nous avons commandé une étude à la firme
de consultants de dez bryant pour
comparer les pourcentages de vendeurs
chinois et canadiennes sur amazon.ca la
plateforme canadienne d'amazon
j'étais étonné de voir qu'il y avait
très peu de vendeurs canadiens je
m'attendais à 30 ou 40% jeu seulement
16% des vendeurs des produits les plus
vendus sur amazon point ces arts sont
canadiens soixante deux pour cent sont
basés en chine à la chine est
le pire ennemi je dirais des vendeurs
amazon tous les fournisseurs qui s'ils
veulent ou s'ils me your les yeux et
commence à vendre leurs produits sur la
plateforme amazon c'est ce qu'on
pourrait pas battre leurs prix c'est le
fournisseur ça pourrait devenir la
nouvelle tendance les manufacturiers
chinois qui contourne les vendeurs
canadiens pour vendre directement sur
amazon
l amazone privilégie le lien direct avec
le consommateur elle permet aux
manufacturiers chinois de contourner les
intermédiaires canadien est de vendre
directement canadien les consommateurs
aiment ça parce que les prix sont plus
bas mais comme canadien je ne pense pas
que ce soit une bonne chose d' éliminer
les intermédiaires
ces intermédiaires des vendeurs comme
marco même s'il vend des produits
fabriqués en chine entonne impact
positif sur l'économie canadienne moi je
paie mes impôts ici l'on si quelqu'un
achète mes produits sur amazon même les
imposons pas d'ici ce qui n'est pas le
cas des vendeurs chinois qu amazon
courtisent sans relâche et en
infrastructure faire tous vendeurs en
chine est stupéfiante
amazon tient des conférences à gauche et
à droite en chine pour recruter des
vendeurs
si vous avez 20 ans et que vous vivez en
chine ça représente une énorme
opportunité de vendre des produits aux
consommateurs canadiens sur
amazon.com c'est un risque d'être
d'année en année de plus en plus
chinoise est de moins en moins
canadienne
j'ai parfois l'impression qu'à ma zone
traite les canadiens comme des vendeurs
de seconde classe
c'est moche mais c'est comme ça
amazon a bouleversé l'ordre mondial du
commerce de détail il appartient
maintenant aux consommateurs d'en tirer
le meilleur sans provoquer le pire
qu'est-ce qu'elle consommateurs qui
magasinent sur amazon qu'est-ce qui doit
réaliser qu'ils pensent plus loin que
son ca transaction qu'est-ce que cet
achat la pour cause et autour de moi
qu'on parle de ddd des impacts fiscaux
l'impact redistribution de richesses et
ces choses là qu'on voit pakala bouabré
narines
[Musique]
claude larose jeune retraité à deux
jouets préférés sa luxueuse voiture
électrique et son enceinte etc ou
d'amazon alex à
[Musique]
ses côtés pratico pratique si on veut de
la technologie cage alors allumé cuisine
fermée buffet a juste mon thermostat à
20 degrés d'accord alexa peut envoyer
vos commandes à des milliers d'appareils
wifi grâce à l amazone vous entend et
avec ces appareils de sécurité au ring
amazon vous vois
quelqu'un qu'elle apporte donc très
bientôt une caméra drone sera disponible
pour l'intérieur de la maison
ça remplace beaucoup de choses en ce
sens comme ma liste d'épicerie banlieue
de la première note je la dis vocalement
alexa alex a ajouté chips sur liste
d'achats les appareils d'amazon
enregistre et transmettent une foule
d'informations vous concernant dans les
serveurs de l'entreprise
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ramassent d'aller
là
c'est dans le but de vendre quelque
chose c'est
c'est vraiment le but principal
l'objectif pour amazon cédait d'une
classe a6 de data ainsi des données pour
anticiper nos besoins avant que nous
mêmes on arriva dans le jour où
qu'amazon commence déjà à m'envoyer des
produits avant quelques chevaux courent
en cas de besoin puis que la boîte
arrive à ma porte ah ben oui c'est vrai
quelle bonne idée ça va d'un avantage
concurrentiel
vraiment fort
voici amazon réole amazon aura bientôt
tout un arsenal de données
supplémentaires
le bracelet lots lancées en 2020 va en
savoir beaucoup plus que les autres
moniteur d'activité relo utilise la
caméra de votre téléphone pour connaître
votre pourcentage de graisse corporelle
c'est sûr que l'on
oublie mitteland d'ingérence au niveau
de la vie privée
le nouveau territoire d'expansion
d'amazon c'est la santé en 2018 elle a
acheté pile pas qu un service de
pharmacie en ligne et depuis peu elle
offre des services de télémédecine leur
estime pour nous divulguer autant
l'information à une compagnie comme
amazon si le conflit d'intérêts on
pourrait arriver à une étape où d'un
côté on veut encourager à manger de plus
de sucre et rip d'un côté on va nous
encourager à consommer plus de pilules
pour traiter le diabète
plusieurs gouvernements à travers le
monde se demande comment faire face à la
croissance galopante d'amazon
la commission européenne a ouvert deux
enquêtes sur les pratiques
potentiellement
anticoncurrentiel de l'entreprise le
bureau canadien de la concurrence mène
aussi sa propre enquête depuis un an et
aux états unis on a recommandé
l'adoption de lois qui pourrait empêcher
amazon d'entrer en concurrence directe
avec ses vendeurs
si cela entraînait une hausse des prix
on pourrait bien voir les consommateurs
se lever pour protéger amazon c'est sûr
que ça prend une volonté politique
vraiment très forte pour aller à
l'encontre du bien du consommateur son
père soit qu' une loi voynet
baisser le pouvoir d'achat
c'est sûr qu'elle politiquement ça peut
être vu comme un suicide
amazon a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue à la caméra par courriel au
sujet de la concurrence directe entre
amazon et ses vendeurs elle nous a écrit
notre engagement envers nos partenaires
et plus ferme que jamais nous
travaillons fort pour les aider à
réussir
au sujet des suspensions de compte elle
ajoute nous travaillons fort pour
prévenir toute application erronée des
politiques nous veillons à ce que les
vendeurs disposent de délais suffisants
pour les demandes de documentation
pour ce qui est des retours abusif vous
vous souvenez de l'expérience que nous
avons tenté avec les mocassins de
jonathan amazon écrit nous prenons les
mesures nécessaires dans les rares cas
où les clients font un usage abusif de
notre politique de retour mais dans les
faits jonathan je vous dois de l'argent
mais voilà en fait je vous dois 83
dollars et
22 sous parce que j'ai acheté cette
jolie paire de mocassins et j'y
retournais cette vieille pas de
mocassins payées 2 dollars et j'étais
complètement remboursé par amazon
aurait pour vrai il ya tellement volumes
élevés sur amazon qui contrôle pour ce
qui se passe dans le bar le détail
depuis neuf semaines 10% seulement des
700 paire de mocassins que jonathan a
envoyé chez amazon ont été vendus
j'aimerais ça ça aille plus vite
mais on se rend compte qu amazon c'est
une plateforme sur la casse est
difficile de se démarquer pour une
marque nouvelle comme nous mais on
travaille dessus puis on voit une
progression jonathan est convaincu qu'à
long terme amazon aura un impact positif
sur sa compagnie il n'a pas perdu espoir
juste un peu de naïveté moi en tant que
vendeur d'amazon je suis juste 1 1
morceaux du puzzle qui sert amazon avant
on à son client directement chez le
client d'abord et avant tout
[Musique]